well many companies had outstanding
products in terms of their performance
and yet their sales don't take off they
might even have products they're
superior to their competitors in terms
of their functions or features and yet
the marketplace just doesn't get
energized and built to love we reveal
how to create products that excite the
marketplace because whether it's a
consumer product or a
business-to-business product the
products more than what it does it also
is how it makes the people feel and
that's what gets consumers excited when
a product doesn't just do the right
things but it makes people feel the
right ways everybody has products that
they're passionate about they love those
products whether they are products that
engage them or the deliver fulfilling or
rewarding experiences but so many
companies still miss the boat they might
deliver a technology that isn't
meaningful or they make promises about
dreams that they're going to fulfill but
they leave us disappointed we wrote
built to love because we research
developed and practice new methods of
innovation they get to the heart of a
customer that to talk about how you
create products that really engage the
marketplace products that are built to
love
well we research teach and consult in
the area of innovation we've advised
over 200 innovation teams at the
University and it companies resulting in
dozens of patents we even have seven
patents between us we've worked with
large companies such as Apple and
Procter & Gamble and we've worked with
small countries as well companies like
red zone robotics a maker of sewer
inspection robots or design event
systems a software company so we've
studied a variety of companies and we've
run and analyzed experiments that get at
the heart of what customers look for in
a product what we found is that
companies are really comfortable with a
type of innovation which leads to
performance in technology improvements
but companies lack a process for the
type of innovation which captivates
customers
well we're really privileged to be at
Carnegie Mellon Carnegie Mellon has
leading areas and those that are
relevant for product development we have
a leading School of Design a leading
School of Engineering and a leading
business school all together in close
proximity and not only that we also have
a culture of collaboration where
professors and students from each of
these schools are customed and energized
and working together on projects and on
research and in writing the book we
leverage that interdisciplinary
environment at Carnegie Mellon really
the book built to love is an evolution
of my work with Peter our earlier books
looked at the nature of
interdisciplinary collaboration in
product development and why it's
important and built to love it's assumed
to be a given and really we're talking
about the power that it gives you to
create emotions in products that are so
exciting to two different audiences in
different people we're really in the
zone of interdisciplinary work at that
point
Carnegie Mellon is a unique place it's a
world renowned research university but
it's also world-renowned teaching
University we make fundamental
theoretical contributions but yet we're
very applied University and the result
of that is that we have a real
cutting-edge education for our students
and our students both appreciate that
and develop emotions around their
response to that they also have the
emotions of just being in this
environment the accessibility to people
their collaborations interactions those
emotions not only create a great
experience for our students while
they're here but it stays with them
throughout their life and that's the
emotion surrounding the university